would you like to sample our vegan bacon
100 meatless yes please
another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this
I don't think I can give you any more I
want one
what a gorgeous herbaceous medley
there's been a mistake you've
accidentally given me the food that my
food eats salad is traditionally the
first course at a wedding there's a
gerbil marrying a rabbit
I'm in charge of food for the wedding so
I brought in pawnee's three best
Caterers and a panel of experts Chris
loves vegetables Ron loves meat and Tom
considers himself a foodie which
apparently means taking Instagrams of
food instead of eating it Indianapolis
is home to Charles Mulligan's Steakhouse
the best damn Steakhouse in the damn
State I have taken a picture of every
steak I've ever eaten there June 2004
porterhouse medium rare bearnaise sauce
January 2000 they call this one the
enforcer February 96 the steak rib eye
the whiskey lagavulin 16. the lady next
to me a
specifically my ex-wife Tammy okay this
is this is the first time I ever went
there oh look at me just a kid
Ron would you like some salad since I am
not a rabbit no I do not try it sounds
good for you you got it
delicious hey Ann if you get this I
don't know if you should come up here
he's not worth it okay
homie let me know where you are and if
you have
Ron what in the devil's name is this
portobello mushrooms where's the Steak
well there's no steak that's a healthier
option it's organically grown
okay can you get us a cold compress or
something
speaking of bad reviews computers are
mostly pointless but that Yelp thing
gave me a great idea on how to criticize
people in places
I am composing strongly worded letters
about things I disapprove of and I am
using the internet to get addresses
where I can send them so far I've
written to a vegetable farm several
European ambassadors a manufacturer of
male cologne and a non-fat Frozen Yogurt
Bar
dear frozen yogurt you are the celery of
desserts be ice cream or be nothing zero
Stars
I help you yeah I own lettuce eat the
vegan restaurant on Lowell Drive and I
wanted to know why you nailed this
letter to my door veganism is the sad
result of a morally corrupt mind
reconsider your life
because I believe it good day carnivores
you're all the same
how did that guy know where to find you
I assume he saw my name and address at
the bottom of the letter I nailed to his
door you signed your real name of course
I did what's going to happen a vegan is
going to physically attack me
they are basically made of glass
Christopher got a second Hey Ron listen
I've eaten a commissary hamburger for
lunch every day for 12 years I just
wanted to make sure this pointless
Health Crusade won't affect the only
part of my job that I like oh no those
hamburgers are gone red meat can cause
sluggishness heart disease even
impotence has the opposite effect on me
turkey burger is that a fried turkey leg
inside a grilled hamburger if so yes
delicious a turkey burger you take lean
ground turkey meat you make that into a
burger instead of red meat why would
anyone do that to themselves what if I
told you that I could make a turkey
burger that tastes better than any other
Burger you've ever had
challenge accepted cook off later today
in the courtyard if I win hamburgers
remain in the commissary what do I get
if I win the rarest Jewel of all victory
over me Ron Swanson I like that
we're on
Ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes plenty
no you need to drink water usually I
take it neat but I will make an
exception in the name of Health
how many drinks of alcohol do you
consume a week one that's it one drink
one Shelf
do you exercise yes love making and
woodworking do you have any history of
mental illness in your family I have an
uncle who does yoga your blood pressure
looks fine I'm not sure how this is
possible but your cholesterol is 120
which is the lowest I've ever seen
what's cholesterol and the only problem
I see is that your potassium is low so
just eat a banana once in a while no
thank you I live the way I live I eat
the things I eat and I'll die the way
I'll die that's oddly beautiful but also
stupid you're not alone in the world
anymore Ron you're dating a woman who
has two kids so every three days think
about Ivy and Zoe and Diane and eat a
damn banana
foreign
ladies ladies
ladies
[Applause]
foreign
hey guys Amber Annie Bill Johnny
no I don't plan to buy anything here I
buy my burger ingredients at food and
stuff a discount Food Outlet equidistant
from my home and my work
I came here for the same reason people
go to the zoo
shh look at that thing
nature is amazing
Leslie needs to butt out the whole point
of this country is if you want to eat
garbage balloon up to 600 pounds and die
of a heart attack at 43. UK
me that's
I didn't invite you you came here anyway
I respect that because you made a choice
as a free American
what are you eating I call this Turf and
turf it's a 16 ounce T-Bone and a 24
ounce porterhouse also Whiskey and a
cigar I'm going to consume all of this
at the same time because I am a free
American the cigars inside sir
fine I will smoke the entire thing
outside even though it is bad for me I
am going to do it
gin and tonic please belay that order
Dana lagavula neat
clear alcohols are for rich women on
diets I humbly placed before you my East
Meets West patented Traeger turkey
burger an Asian fusion Burger made with
Willow farms organic turkey a toasted
telegio cheese crisp papaya Chutney
black truffle aioli and micro Greens on
a gluten-free brioche bun enjoy mmm
this taste is delicious as Beyonce
smells
I'm guessing what is what is this in
here
well somebody's got a sharp palette I
love the Umami flavor
stop being so pretentious Kyle sorry
there's mine it's a hamburger made out
of meat on a bun with nothing
add ketchup if you want I couldn't care
less
Ron
I'm so disappointed I thought that you
and I were going to have a real
challenge never mind this is better what
um
Kyle
sorry Andy Ron's is better damn
oh my gosh so much better it's crazy
turkey can never beat cow Chris sorry
I don't understand I I've tinkered with
this recipe for years granted it's been
a long time since I've had a hamburger
foreign
the commissary will continue to serve
horrifying artery clogging hamburger
[Applause]
there's only one thing I hate more than
lying
skim milk which is water that's lying
about being milk